معي من الخرطوم الان الدكتور منتصر محمد
عثمان وهو مدير الاداره العامه للطوارئ
الصحيه ومكافحه الاوبئه في وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه اهلا بك دكتور اسمح لي ان ابدا
بصوره وربما جرد كامل بصوره عامه لما
وثقتموه ورصت طموح حتى الان حول الوضع
الصحي الى احد كانت هذه الهدنه وان تقطعت
الاشتباكات فيها ولا زالت مستمره في بعض
النقاط اعطتكم صوره اوضح عن الوضع الصحي
بصوره عامه في الخرطوم
دكتور منتصر هل تسمعني
كنت قد سالتك عن الوضع بصوره عامه في
الخرطوم وان كانت الهدنه رغم هشاشتها
اعطتكم الامكانيه لرصد واقع الحال فيما
يتعلق بالقطاع الصحي والوضع الصحي بصوره
عامه
اختي العزيزه نحن الزملاء في الولايات
وزاره الصحه الولائيه بالخرطوم الاخرى ان
نتابع بصوره دوريه مع بقياده الاخ لوكيل
وزير الصحه المكلف فعل
الحاله الصحيه الوضع الصحي للسودان بصوره
دوريه يكاد يكون كل ساعه وكل شيء المناطق
المكسره بالنسبه لينا في ولايه الخرطوم هي
اكثر منطقه متاثره
الوحدات الصحيه هي العامل الان هي في
المناطق الطرفيه المناطق في وسط الخرطوم
المناطق اللي فيها الصراع حتى مع الهدنه
ما في طريقه للحركه لانه لم استطيع ان
ناخذ ممرات امنه
باقي الوضع على حاله دكتور منتصر بمعنى
اخر لم تستطيعوا حتى اعاده تشغيل اي من
النقاط الطبيه الموجوده على الارض او
الوصول الى المحتاجين في مناطق محدده
الوحدات الصحيه عندنا اكثر من 90 مستشفى
الان يعمل في ولايه الخرطوم ولايه الخرطوم
اكثر المناطق متاثره هي المنطقه المركزيه
فيها حوالي 30 لتقيل وتزيد على حسب
المنطقه المتاثره فيها المعرفه للوحدات
الصحيه عندنا مراكز صحيه الان ايضا تعمل
وفيها اطباء حتى فيها اخصائيين في جزء من
المراكز الصحيه بتقوم بدور الاسعافات
الاوليه وتحول للمستشفيات بالذات
المستشفيات الطرفيه الاثر في ولايه
الخرطوم موجود في المنطقه الوسطيه اللي
فيها المعركه
اذا كان على مستوى الخرطومه او مستوى بحري
نعم
وماذا عن
الحاجات الان بالنسبه لكم فيما يتعلق
بامكان الادويه او غيرها من الاجهزه وكان
هناك وعود من منظمه الصحه العالميه
بايصال بعض منها
بالنسبه لنا
الادويه او الادويه للعمليات الجراحيه
طلبت من الاخوه بمصدر الصحه العالميه وهم
في طريقهم الان لتوفيرها خلال
الاسبوع هذا الاسبوع لتصل القاهره يوم
الاحد ان شاء الله
خلال هذا الاسبوع طب خبرنا عن العمليات
الجراحيه وكيف تسير وان كان لديكم بعض
الارقام فيما يتعلق بالوضع بصوره عامه ان
كان العمليات او اعداد من قتلوا خلال هذه
الاشتباكات واليوم يتم الحديث عن ان هناك
اشتباكات متفرقه في اكثر من منطقه هل
رصدتم اي اصابات او حالات وفاه او لا
التقرير بيجينا خلال اليوم
بالنسبه لايه
كل الاصابات كل المحولين المرضى
الوفيات من الولايات ومن ضمنهم ولايه
الخرطوم بالنسبه لولايه الخرطوم والولايات
الاخرى حتى الان عندنا حوالي اربعه 1599
مصاب حتى تاريخهم 28
و528
توفي الى رحمه مولاهم نحسبهم الشهداء
وعلل الشفاء للمصابين عمليه النزوح هل
تتابعونها وهل من حالات مرضيه معينه تم
رصدها دكتور منتصر بالفتره الحاليه
الاخيره
النزوح الرسمي
للجهات نحن عندنا نزوح مثلا في ولايه
الجزيره لداخليات لمراكز حكوميه هذا يرسخ
وحتى الحالات المحوله منه
والمعالجه منها النزوح الاخر
للناس اللي بيرحلوا اذا كان او يعني
اهلهم او اذا كان
بياجروا بيت هي ما مرصوده لكن المتابعه
بتكون عن طريق الوحدات الصحيه للحالات
المحوله من الخرطوم عندنا رفض يومي
للحالات المحوله من الخرطوم
لمستشفيات بالولاد بالذات المستشفيات
للولايات المجاوره نهر النيل الجزيره
نتحدث عن حالات اصابات او حالات مرضيه
عاديه وهل من تخوف ايضا من انتشار اوبئه
بعينها
في هذا الوضع اكيد نحن نتخوف من انتشار
اوجاع لازم نكون نحن دقيقين في انه نتابع
الحالات مع الشحا المياه
ممكن تجينا اي اسهالات
مرصد هذا مع الاخوه في الولايات نحن
المسؤوليه المسؤوليه الطوارئ هي لرصد
الحالات للمتابعه للتنسيق للاستجابه
للطوارئ ومن ضمنها الطارئه الان الحاصل
لذلك الاخوه في وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه
الان
متابعين للحالات
في المناطق الطرفيه اللي كانت في دول
بتبلغ الاحالات رسالات بالاضافه للمناطق
الان فيها شحم المياه
وبتيجي فيها يشربوا مباشره من مياه النيل
او الابار
الغير مخصوصه الناس بتتابع فيهم ونتوقع
انه خلال الخريف اذا استمر للاسف هذه
استمرت هذه المعرفه خلال الخريف ممكن
نجابه بامراض امراض المنقوله عبر النواقل
كالبعوض
من الخرطوم دكتور منتصر محمد عثمان مدير
الاداره العامه للطوارئ الصحيه ومكافحه
الاوبئه في وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه شكرا
جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات